قال الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل ماكرو ان
الوضع الانساني في غزه لا يزال حرجا ولهذا
قدمت فرنسا والاردن مساعدات عبر الجو
للسكان هناك وقام سلاح الجو الفرنسي
بالاشتراك مع جيش الجيش الاردني فجر
الجمعه بعمليه انزال لعده شحنات من
المعونات الانسانيه الغذائيه والطبيه فوق
قطاع غزه وتحديدا فوق المستشفى الاردني
الميدني جنوب قطاع غزه واوضح الاليزيه
لمراسل الجزيره في باريس ان المساعدات
توزع لكافه المحج المحتاجين ولكن نقطه
الانزال والتوزيع كانت في محيط المستشفى
الاردني باستخدام طائرتين واحده تابعه
للجيش الفرنسي والاخرى للجيش الاردني من
طراز سي 130 واضاف ليزي ان هذ ان هذه
المساعدات تاتي في اطار التعبئه الانسانيه
التي تقوم بها فرنسا لصالح المدنيين في
قطاع
غزه هذا وقال الس السفير الفرنسي في
الاردن في تصريح للجزيره ان بلاده شاركت
مع الاردن في انزال جوي لمساعدات تحتوي
على معدات طبيه وانسانيه لصالح المستشفى
الميداني الاردني والمستشفيات الاخرى
مشيرا الى ان هناك تنسيقا مع الاردن حاليا
من اجل استقبال جرحى من غزه للعلاج في
المستشفيات
الفرنسيه سحمت فرنسا الليله الماضيه في
عمليه انزال مشتركه مع الاردن فتم انزال
سب صنادق صنادق تحتوي على معدات بيه
وانسانيه لصالح المستشفى الميداني الاردني
بجانب غزه يعني بخانيونس بالذات فهذه
عمليه غير مسبوقه بالنسبه لفرنسا وهي جزء
من شركه انسانيه فرنسيه اردنيه تضم عده
عمليات